[Music]
Univision now is a direct consumer
subscription offering the goal was to
give access to our audience wherever
they are whenever they wanted when we
really wanted to innovate and push the
boundaries on our subscription service
we launched in app subscriptions for
Google Places and we saw it pop
immediately that three to four times the
conversion rate by working with the
Google team when we started a Nogami we
said we want to have a music service
which is convenient and all the music
available in the Middle East it was a
region which was totally forgotten there
was no legal eternity so you have to
fight it or hide it and there was
nothing else and if we actually could
succeed we'd be piloting the pilot for
us we'll play is the core we have over
81 percent of our users today on Android
our growth strategy goes around engaging
Android users to use up more so they can
subscribe making that Google Play giving
when you have increase of subscription
conversion rate on an action and meeting
that the main condition is the better
user experience Android and become the
main source for download : acting up
also we see my subscription conversion
and increase of X percent on Android
congrats and other problems
Felix started with the vision to make
everyone the greatest version of
themselves and the way we do this is
we're trying to motivate and guide them
with variety of apps to reach their
physical and mental goals the reason why
is a clicking negative sense for us is
not only communicate on the point of
view but also because we want to develop
it in the long run we want to have a
repeated impact on their life working
with Google Play and figuring out how to
launch a successful subscription product
it's been great and that kind of
partnership is really what we saw that
led to the success
[Music]
good morning everybody
so first off well done for make it in on
Friday morning and for me and these two
thank you very much hello to everyone on
the livestream
as well I want to dive straight into it
and I want to go straight into it with
all of you so can you all put your hands
up please
every single one of you I'm going to
shame anyone who doesn't brilliant okay
if you're on the livestream can you
pretty up keep them up if you're the
live stream can you put your hand up as
well just say you look really odd in
your office okay
could you put your hand down if you
don't want to make more money someone
just put their hand up in the front row
that's amazing it's like no Ritu okay
thanks very much you put your hands down
now okay so the good news is you're all
in the right session because this is all
about making more money with
subscriptions and with Google Play now
why subscriptions
well basically subscriptions are we
think the best way to make more revenue
more regularly and more reliably on
Google Play and who doesn't want to make
more cash more reliably and more
regularly but all of you guys are going
to be a different part of your
subscription lifecycle all of you are
going to be at different points and
integrating with us now the three of us
are really excited about subscriptions
but we'd also like to know a bit more
about you as well so I want to get your
hands ready again can you give a thought
about where you are in your app
development journey and if you've
integrated with Play billing so you're
running subscriptions in your apps right
now are you running a successful
business but you want to know how to
take that business to the next level can
you put your hands up so computer hands
up if you integrated with us but want to
know how to really drive success great
thanks very much put your hands down
okay so next if you've just started
integrating with us maybe you're at the
beginning of your journey or you're
considering it and you want to know what
tools we have to help you build your
successful subscriptions business can
you put your hands up please okay a few
of you thanks very much and lastly if
you've not integrated with us if you
maybe like considering subscriptions or
considering using us basically if you're
here because you just want to know what
all the fuss is about with subscriptions
can you put your hands up okay a few of
you hello and welcome so the good news
is that no matter when you put your
hands up or if you're on the live stream
if you thought that sounds like me then
Larry George and I have things to share
for you so today we're going to be
talking to every single one of you in
the room about how play can help you
build successful subscription businesses
now the three of us work with teams
across Google to make that happen that
means that we've been thinking about
subscriptions a huge amount and when we
do we think it starts with one thing it
starts with an awesome product and
that's on you guys you guys make amazing
apps that bring Android to life so
you've done that you've got a brilliant
app and you want to monetize it with
subscriptions what's the next thing you
need well the next thing you need is a
brilliant market you need loads of
people who are really interested in your
product and are willing to pay to use
them but that's not all either the next
thing you need is a best-in-class
billing platform that gives you guys the
tools and the flexibility to be able to
get to that audience and successfully
monetize them now once you've got those
there's one more thing you need to build
a truly successful subscriptions
business and that's best-in-class
insights and reporting because the
better the insights you guys have the
better decisions you make and when you
make great decisions you build great
businesses
so the good news is that no matter where
you put your hands up we've got
something for you if you're wondering
what all the fuss is about
George is going to be sharing
information about the amazing market you
find on android and via play if you put
your hands up because you're really
interested in our tooling Cohan and new
now he's going to be showing some really
exciting information about the new
capabilities of our building platform
and lastly if you put your hands up
because you want to take your business
to the next level you need the insights
to be able to do that and I'll be on at
the end to share some really exciting
information about new insights in
reporting by the play console so let's
get going I'd like to welcome George up
to tell us really what all the fuss is
about
thanks Don hey everyone I'm George and
I'm on the play business development
team working with developers like
yourselves on your subscription business
I am very happy to be here particularly
because subscriptions are seeing a
phenomenal growth on androids just in
the past two years we have doubled
number of active subscribers on play so
between 2016 and 2017 we have twice the
number of people subscribing to your
services and this proves that there is
an audience of users that is really
interested in engaging with your product
but that's not all that's actually only
the latest in a series of positive
momentum we've been seeing subscriptions
have been the fastest growing business
model on Google Play today we've seen a
ten times growth in the past three years
in consumer spends so not only are
people using your services they are also
spending on them
now to validate this we actually really
talked with users and developers and we
know that this phenomenal growth would
not happen if users don't love
subscriptions
fortunately they do personally I love
being able to binge watch the latest
season of sense8 on Netflix or track my
workouts on freeletics or even swipe as
much as I want on tinder without having
to worry about consumption chargers and
Scruffy's and that's why users of
subscriptions that they know that they
can engage with your product as much as
they want and know that they will be
charged that $5 $10 $15 at the end of
the month so I mentioned the consumer
research study that we did recently to
better understand subscribers on Android
and this study really validated this
trend and this growth and this
excitement about subscriptions that
we're seeing we realized that the
audience for subscriptions is out there
and very engaged 62% of subscribers on
androids use their subscription service
at least once a day now this engagement
translates into money we found that
there is a compelling market for
subscriptions coming out of these
engaged users there is a willingness to
pay that ranges anywhere between $5 and
$20 for subscriptions and that really
varies based on the category of the app
we will be making the results of this
consumers research survey available to
you today in a blog post so make sure to
check it out so you can better
understand subscription trends on
Android now let's switch sides to you
guys in the room we know that developers
also love subscriptions otherwise you
wouldn't be here at 10 a.m. on a Friday
developers love subscriptions because
you can generate recurrence revenue from
happy and engaged buyers and who doesn't
want that who doesn't want the peace of
mind that your users are paying you
every month it's expected its recurrence
and it's very easy to model out
thousands of developers use Google Play
billing for their subscriptions today
some of them are here on the screen and
some of them have actually shared with
us a bunch of their studies case studies
and stories about the success that
they're seeing on Android so throughout
this session you will hear from tinder
Netflix coffee meets bagel HBO and many
others so there are loads of great
reasons to choose subscriptions and to
choose play bin
for subscriptions the first of these is
how huge and addressable the market for
subscription on Android is but also how
easy it is to integrate with us and
Larry will touch a bit more on this
later throughout this talk but let me
tell you about the market you may have
heard this incredible stat from the
keynote a few days ago two billion
monthly active devices on Android today
that's pretty good right these are
billions of users that you can reach
through Google Play billing with a
simple integration we enable you to sell
your subscriptions to the billions of
users across the world now this is
pretty cool but it's also somewhat scary
it's pretty complex to put together a
subscription business think of it you
have to worry about local market
understanding regulation taxes I mean
who doesn't love to think about taxes
across the world right refunds order
management so many things have to come
together to create a compelling
subscription story compelling
subscription product luckily we take all
of that away from you we do a huge
amount of that for you so that's all you
have to do is plug and play no pun
intended
so coffee meets bagel for example is the
case study of a of an app and the dating
space who typically had been using
in-app purchases but wanted to get in on
the all the frenzy around subscriptions
and wanted to introduce the subscription
skew and their products by partnering
with Google Play they were able to do so
very quickly and within a few months
they were offering a subscription skew
globally without having to worry about
local payment integration various
regulations etc all they did is create a
subscription skew integrate with
labeling and now subscriptions generate
40% of the revenue for coffee meets
bagel all right so we established that
the audience for subscription services
is out there engaged and willing to pay
the android market is huge with billions
of users that you can reach and that
it's very easy to integrate Google Play
billing so now Larry will tell us about
the bidding platform and how the global
reach and innovative features of
labeling can really help you propel your
subscription business to success Larry
thanks George good morning everyone my
name is Larry yang I'm the product
manager for the Google Play billing
platform when I think about subscription
success I think it really just comes
down to two key factors acquisitions and
retention
let me walk you through some of the key
features that the Play billing platform
provides to help you in these two areas
first let's talk about acquisition play
billing offers three important tools to
help you acquire new users we bring you
our extensive payment reach we have
amazing introductory features and last
but probably most important we have an
amazingly simple user payment experience
let's talk about our payment reach first
Google Play billing is available in over
a hundred 30 countries today but it's
not enough just to offer any old form of
payment you need to offer the preferred
form of payment and it turns out payment
preparation is more a function of
culture than it is socioeconomic status
for example in North America of course
credit cards are very popular but it
turns out PayPal is super important in
Germany and other European countries in
regions where cash is still king our
Play credit and gift cards have been a
big hit and in the asia-pacific region
and throughout the Middle East carrier
billing is a must-have let me talk a
little bit more about these last two
gift cards and carrier billing
we've offered our gift cards for a while
now to allow users to purchase play
content and earlier this year we
extended that ability to subscriptions
in areas where cash is still very
popular we've seen a tremendous increase
in subscriptions spent in some areas as
high as 15% so we're super excited to
bring this new form of payment to your
subscriptions business now let's talk a
bit about carrier billing earlier this
week you might have heard us announce
that we now have billing partnerships
with over a hundred 40 mobile carriers
and across all those partnerships we now
reach 900 million active devices that's
900 million devices whose users can now
pay for your content directly from their
phone they don't need a credit card they
don't need a bank account they just need
their phone so those are a few examples
of our payment reach and how that helps
you grow your business now let's talk
about some of our flexible introductory
capabilities we've had free trial
support for a while now it's a great way
for you to introduce your content to
prospective subscribers without them
having to make a long-term commitment
turns out when we talk to users over
three-quarters of them started a
subscription offering so there's some
sort of free experience so it's no
wonder that almost all of our top
subscription apps and partners all offer
some sort of free experience now in
addition to free trials last year we
offered introductory pricing this gives
you the ability to offer a limited time
discount for your service when we talk
to users we learned that getting some
sort of a discount was the number two
driver for conversion and that was
second only to the desire of wanting to
get continued and additional content and
that makes sense
after all who doesn't love a great deal
Larry actually a great example of a
developer who ran an introductory
pricing campaign is a Nogami
and the family is the leading music
streaming service in the Middle East and
they have a premium access which allows
you to get unlimited music now anthem is
usually priced at $5 a month but they
did a weekend promotion where they
offered the service for three dollars
for three months so that's about 80% in
saving the results were impressive they
saw it's 400% increase in daily average
orders during that weekend compared to
their average daily signups that's five
times the number of buyers going in and
signing up to the service and
interestingly after three months after
the promotion was over the majority of
these users actually ended up staying on
the service and recurring at full price
thanks George that's a great example of
how one of our developers is seeing
subscription success with our platform
so now let me talk about our third tool
that helps you acquire new users our
seamless user payment experience imagine
a free-for-all world where users have to
read multiple different terms of
services they have to enter their
sensitive information multiple times
sometimes their address sometimes their
zip code sometimes other information and
they have to do that over and over and
over again
well that nightmare is over play
Billings makes it simple the user enters
their payment information once and never
again and it turns out that the majority
of our purchase is finished without the
user having to enter their payment
information and besides as a developer
do you really want to be maintaining and
managing all of that sensitive
information of course not so instead of
entering their information with multiple
companies they just do it once with
Google and when we ask users how that
felt
they told us it just feels safe and why
does safety and trust matter well turns
out trust the more users trust the
company they work with the more likely
they are going to spend money
68% of users associate trust with making
a purchase that was the number one
correlated factor in this survey there
I'm standing here because I have a
feeling I'm going to keep interrupting
you
so as actually I just want to add that
the seamless experience and distrust the
developers put into Google Play and the
ease of the flow delivers results we've
seen it that at the moment of purchase
you really want to capture this intent
with as minimal friction as possible as
few steps as possible with Google Play
billing you can do it with only two
steps and this is translating into
positive conversion results for some of
our partners for example the New York
Times when they introduced Google Play
billing they saw a hundred twenty five
percent increase in conversions just one
month after doing so Univision now when
they launched their subscription service
and moved it from a web based payment
flow to Google Play billing they saw a
spike of three to four times conversion
lists and you saw in the video about
lomatin al which sees six percent better
conversions on Android than on non
Android platforms so if you look at this
all together this means that we take the
effort out of implementing of out of
implementation but we also deliver
results and this is why HBO decided to
use and rely Google Play billing for
their subscription service HBO now
because we allow an end-to-end
experience to users where they don't
have to remove their credit cards from
their wallet but we also allow an
end-to-end payment platform for HBO
which enables them to again plug and
play and get going immediately thanks
George so those are some examples of how
our payment reach our introductory
features and our payment experience help
you acquire new users so now that you
have all these great happy new users let
me talk about a couple things we do to
help you keep them help you retain them
so last year we launched a future grace
period grace period is a way for you to
give your users 3 or 7 extra day
days to correct any sort of payment
issues that might have happened when
they were renewing in their subscription
well it turns out that developers who
are using grace period are seeing over a
50 percent improvement in recovery from
those sorts of involuntary cancellations
so if you're a developer with
subscriptions and you're not already
using grace periods you really should
just get on the play console right now
and turn on that feature it's literally
just flipping a switch but there's still
a problem with grace period users are
lazy it's just too easy for them to
dismiss a notification or ignore an
email and keep consuming your content
without having to pay for it so today
I'm pleased to announce we're rolling
out a new feature account fold with a
count fold we work with you to block
access to your precious content so now
we've increased the level of pain just
enough for the user now they need to
actually go and fix that form of payment
in order to restore access to your
content we have over a dozen developers
in early access right now using account
hold and we plan on bringing that out
over the alo later next month so we
piloted this feature with deep safe
which is one of those developers who
were in the early access program keep
safe is an app which allows you to store
your photos and videos and protect them
so you can have a PIN protection around
your videos they're very popular on
Android and they have a subscription
business which allows you as a premium
user to access your photos in the clouds
and and various other exciting features
now because their subscription service
is really important for them they
integrated with account hold and they
saw this 25% increase in renewal rates
on Android and this is because to
Larry's point when users get this
notification that their account is will
be suspended unless they change their
form of payment
they are much more likely to go and act
on it so these are a few examples of how
the Google Play billing platform helps
you build a successful subscription
business
and speaking of success one of the next
one of the partners that we have worked
with very closely is Netflix which is
the leading subscription service in the
world we've partnered very closely with
them to enable them to scale their app
globally but also to make payments
effortless through Google Play billing
for Netflix subscribers around the world
the figures and the the acquisition and
the retention numbers that Netflix is
seeing through Google Play billing are
very promising and are delivering
subscription success in over a hundred
countries but that's not all our team
has been listening to you and they're
hard at work on a number of new
capabilities that we'll be rolling out
soon we're going to give you more
flexibility in how you set up and offer
your SKUs we're going to make it easier
for you to change prices on your
existing subscriptions we're going to
give you more up-to-date information
when a subscription status changes say
when a user cancels or they go on hold
and we're going to make it easier for
you to integrate and test the Play
billing so stay tuned over the next few
months so now that you have all these
amazing new tools at your fingertips how
do you know which ones to try how do you
know what's working how do you know
which ones aren't working well in order
to answer those questions you need
fantastic insights and reporting Tom why
don't you share some other stuff that
your team is working on in this area
cool thanks Larry hello again everybody
so I work with teams in Google Play some
of whom are actually in the audience
hello everyone now the huge advantage of
Google Play is that we are for all
intents and purposes the single point of
truth for a number of key events in your
apps lifecycle these are events like
people looking at your Play Store
listing installing your app taking out
your free trial or every single
recurrent payment for a subscriber now
it's that team's job to get that
information out to you guys in a way
which is actionable and insightful
basically we're dedicated in
a subscription metrics out to all
developers for running subscriptions
businesses if I'm honest the play
console hasn't been fantastic at that in
the past but we know that you need that
information to run your businesses and
make decisions which is why I'm really
happy to save earlier this week we
launched a granny a brand-new part of
the play console the subscriptions
dashboard the subscriptions dashboard is
easily found in the revenue section on
the play menu and it pulls together key
overarching information about your subs
so for instance it easily plots total
subscriptions and new activations and
cancellations all in one place it also
pulls together your bottom line
so it shows you your daily and 30-day
recurrent revenue as a stay rolling
revenue and lastly it even easily
displays your top performing products
taken together this dashboard is a
brilliant place to gain insights to look
at your trends and to spot anomalies but
when you do that you're even going to
want to know more right you're going to
see something and you're going to want
to dive into it a really understand
what's going on now when you do want to
know more we have the bottom half of the
dashboard this is a super powerful
cohort eyes view of new subscribers and
it looks at the three the three key
parts of your subscription lifecycle
acquisition retention and cancellation
so let's take a look at each one of
those nice and quickly now to start off
with
we've got acquisition how you acquire
new subscribers where they came from and
also which acquisition channels they
were coming in from as well now this
card is lovely but it's not the only
information we have so the acquisition
report like the other two has a really
powerful click-through report as well so
this gives you much more information
about your subscriptions acquisition
it's built on the really successful
acquisition reports you can already find
in the play console but it's tailored
specifically to your subscription
business so you can see not only which
of your acquisition channels drove the
highest number of free trailers or
installs but also which drove the longer
the largest number of long-term
recurrent high-value subscribers like
the current acquisition channels we have
breakdowns so you can see it if you're
using UTM tagging against every single
one of your campaigns you can link to
Adwords see it against your pay for
campaigns of Google or you can even look
at which Google search traffic drives
the highest number of long-term
subscribers it is super powerful way for
you to gain insight so you can decide
where you're going to focus your
acquisition effort and your acquisition
budget to get you the highest number of
high-value recurrent subscribers so what
do you do next
what do you do when you've got these
subscribers well you want to know what
happens to them with your subscription
and for that we've got the subscriptions
retention report this is brand new and
personally I think it's my favorite of
all it gives you a cohort of subscribers
from different subscriptions so you can
plot different subs against each other
it allows you to see key parts of your
subscription life cycles so in this case
this developer can easily see that just
after their free trial they see a large
drop-off in subscribers this enables you
to make really impactful product
decisions in this case the developer
might choose to remind their subscribers
just before their free trial ends of
what an amazing offer they have or how
fantastic all the content is but that's
not the only thing this does this report
also allows you to easily select
subscriptions to compare to each other
so if you've got a brand new
subscription maybe it's a test one it's
an experiment and you want to see if
it's performing better or worse than
your legacy subs you can easily see it
and this enables you to make really cool
decisions right in this case the
developer might say hey look my
subscription is represented by the red
line clearly outperforming the other
ones this is the one I'm going to put
front and center in my app this
is the one I'm going to push to my users
the attention book report enables you to
make the decisions that lead to higher
value longer terms retained subscribers
we actually show some of these marks due
to some developers and workshops and the
feedback has been very positive so we're
really excited for all of you guys to
try it out
Glu is a developer of subscription games
and they were very excited about this
feature the SKU comparison one yeah they
loved it it was great to see as well
thank you so lastly we've got this sad
report right we've got the cancellation
of all nobody likes people canceling
your subscriptions but it does happen
and the first step in making it happen
less is to accept that it happens and to
find out why and for that we've got the
cancellation report now for the first
time the cancellation report in the play
console allows you to see the exact day
that subscribers choose to cancel and to
make it really useful for you guys to be
able to work out why we helpfully
categorize these cancellations as well
so let's take a look at those categories
to start off
we've got voluntary cancellations
voluntary cancellations are where a user
goes into the goes into play app find
your subscription and just tap cancel if
you've got high voluntary cancellations
you can start doing things like price
testing or maybe you want to look at
what value you're offering is part of
your sub or simply reminding users about
what a great value subscription you
really have next we've got voluntary
cancellation and uninstall this is where
someone only cancels your sub but after
30 days they've uninstalled your app
from every single one of their devices
Rachel yeah painful this is not a good
cancellation if you've got high
uninstall cancel a voluntary and
uninstall cancellations this is the kind
of point where you want to start looking
at the new Android vital section on the
Play console to take a look at whether
you've got high crashes high ANR's or
janky air
or maybe you want to take a look at our
new advanced reviews analysis to see
what users are telling you about your
app or where you can improve it and
lastly we've got involuntary
cancellations these are classically
associated with payment failures if
you've got high and voluntary
cancellations then the kinds of features
that Larry spoke about earlier like
grace periods and account hold exactly
what you should be looking at and the
cancellation report especially when it
comes to account hold enables you to
build a business model to be able to put
your Android devs on to account hold to
build that feature out taken together
this gives you a view into your
cancellations which you've never been
able to have before but sometimes it's
hard to tell what to do so having that
insight is only the first step so
launching with the cancellation report
then we're also starting to add more
more active guidance this is where our
teams are saying to you hey we've
noticed this anomaly you might want to
try this tool it will help your business
get better so that is the dashboard a
brand new way to look at all of your
subscriptions data on the play console
all in one place I'm really happy to say
that all of the time series trends that
you can see up on the screens now are
available today in the play dashboard in
the play console and the second half
those cohorted views and the click
throughs will be launched in the coming
weeks I'd like to take just a second to
say why I and the teams here really care
about this we really really care about
getting all of you better subscriptions
reporting and that's because we know the
better reporting allows all of you to
have better insights and the better your
subscriptions insights are the better
the decisions you make around them and
the better decisions you make around
them the better businesses you build and
the more successful apps you run on
Android do you know who really cares
about this - Tom who vendor they said
they will swipe right you're a new
subscription dashboard so that's a match
George all I've ever wanted is on swipe
right
and I will take it on the dashboard good
all right so to wrap up what's all the
fuss about
well George told you earlier about how
subscriptions is one of the fastest
growing businesses and how a lot of
developers are already today taking
advantage of Android in play to grow
their subscriptions business and if at
the beginning you really wanted to know
about the tools that we have to help you
succeed
Larry shared both existing and brand-new
tools to help you really drive your
acquisition and your attention and
across at all if you're looking to
improve your subscription business
through insights and reporting which can
power your decision-making Tom shared
the latest in our powerful new
subscriptions reporting tools so taken
together all of this means that Android
is a great platform to reach users
convert them generate more revenue out
of them and do so more regularly and
more reliably than ever before so thank
you so much for attending we will be
here to take any questions you might
have so there are microphones on each
side of the room but before we do so we
want to thank you again for being here
on behalf of all three of us and we hope
that you found this session helpful
[Music]